ce n'est pas une vie normale pour moi ce
travail est trop dure beaucoup trop dieu
tous les jours lorsqu'on descend au fond
de la mine on risque notre vie et on a
peur beaucoup ils sont restés stables et
comme c'est dangereux ici c'est sauter
on vit comme dira sans jamais voir la
lumière du jour et nous ça pour cent
durant la semaine
alors qu'on se ruinent la santé à cause
du gaz et de la houille
on respire sans cesse vraiment il
faudrait qu'un jour on arrête de jouer
avec nos vies
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
bon
[Musique]
je descends fonda mines les armements et
j'ai du mal à respirer
j'ai l'impression de vivre dans un autre
monde un monde dort à l'obscurité est
plus noir que la nouille csii mines de
charbon je suis content de travailler
ici parce qu'on gagne bien on est payés
au rendement évidemment c'est dur très
dur même
mais il faut se défoncer au maximum pour
faire son quota de charbon le plus vite
possible et pouvoir ensuite aller se
reposer ou dormir
moi je travaille huit heures par jour du
lundi au samedi
[Musique]
nous les enfants nous embauchent ici
parce qu'on peut se glisser dans les
boyaux étroits
c'est pour ça que les patrons sont
contents de nous avoir papa il est
bientôt quatre heures oui on peut
s'arrêter
je me sens très fatigué
je gagne en moyenne 150 prend la semaine
le père lui ne gagnent que 120 front il
fait moins parce qu'il a du mal à
piocher alors son rendement est plus bas
que le miel on crève de chaud dans la
mine ont plus je me sentais fragile la
tension est élevée
j'ai des problèmes respiratoires je
travaille plus dans toutes les autres
[Applaudissements]
avant d'être ici j'étais agriculteur
mais ce n'était pas rentable je
n'arrivais pas à nourrir ma famille j'ai
huit enfants et même aujourd'hui je ne
peux toujours pas leur payer l'école
nous on a toujours été pauvres faut donc
se résigner à travailler dangereusement
pour survivre je n'oblige pas mon fils à
aller à la mine nous retourner au
village peu de sa mère s'il mais c'est
lui qui insiste pour travailler avec moi
c'est son problème
d'un seul coup d'adel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais préféré aller à l'école bien
sûr mais comme on n'a pas le sou je me
retrouve là à piocher en fait il n'y a
pas d'âge pour faire les études par
exemple dans mon village natal
je connais une veille de 82 ans qui
vient de commencer l'école primaire
alors moi je me dis que j'ai tout le
temps pour étudier d'abord il faut que
je travaille dur dans la mine et
peut-être qu'un jour je réussirai ici
dans la région de touba gars le gros
problème c'est l'exploitation
rudimentaire des mines de charbon les
pères de familles n'hésitent pas à
envoyer leurs enfants faire un travail
très dur et dévastateur pour la santé
mentale de responsabilités paternelles
c'est de l'inconscience car les mines
sont insalubres et dangereuses la
plupart des enfants de la région sont à
l'année une car leurs familles sont
démunis ils vont à l'école le matin et
travail l'après midi certains le font
spontanément parce que c'est une
tradition familiale
d'autres souhaitent aider leurs parents
nécessiteux ils n'ont pas le choix
c'est le cas du jeune rahim et andres
de différent moi je suis veuve et sans
revenus c'est pour cela que mon fils est
obligé de m'aider en allant à la mine
moins trois heures par jour à
l'exception du dimanche son rôle à lui
c'est de décharger le charbon mais il ne
descend pas au fond ah bon tu va sauter
aussi vous voyez je ne sais même pas ce
qu'il leur faut faire là bas c'est vrai
c'est dangereux il peut y avoir du gaz
dans la mine c'est pourquoi je préfère
qu'il n'ya que cette année et l'an
prochain je l'envoie bogota faire un
travail plus sûr
c'est aussi mieux pour les étudiants
moi j'aimerais ne plus descendre dans la
mine
si j'avais les moyens j'arrêterai c'est
sûr mais ici à touba gars on ne peut
rien faire d'autre que ça si on extrait
pas le charbon avec l argent on va
pouvoir se nourrir s'habiller ou étudier
il faut bien payer les livres l'uniforme
et les fournitures scolaires tous les
jours lorsque je descends fond je risque
ma vie et j'ai peur
j'en connais beaucoup qui sont restés
c'est très dangereux ici les mines ne
sont pas entretenus ni étayé il n'y a
aucune sécurité et ça vous tombe sur la
tête comme un rien nous on s'abîme la
santé pour des clopinettes
parfois ça nous fait pleurer lorsqu'on
ne peut plus creusées oui souvent je
pleure de rage ici au fond de la mine
ce sont surtout les poumons qui s'ouvre
on respire tout le temps de la poussière
de boom
on a deux copains qui sont morts
récemment dans la mine
leur père les a obligé à descendre il ya
eu un éboulement et ils ont été associés
depuis cette histoire nous les enfants
on ne voudrait plus aller travailler
cet accident nous a fait peur on nous
oblige quand même à faire ce boulot
vraiment il faudrait qu'un jour on
arrête de jouer avec nos vies il existe
en colombie un règlement sur l'hygiène
et la sécurité qui interdit aux enfants
de moins de 18 ans et aux femmes de
travailler dans les mines
en fait cette loi aurait dû entrer en
vigueur depuis 1989
[Musique]
malheureusement il n'existe pas dans ce
pays de police des mines qui puisse
faire appliquer la législation de
manière stricte les industriels eux
s'accommode très bien de cette situation
qui ils profitent de l'anarchie du
marché et du grand nombre de petites
mines artisanales non officiel pour
acheter le charbon à bas prix bien sûr
on ne devrait pas tolérer ces
exploitations illégales mais comment
faire si on les ferme tout on risque de
créer un véritable fléau social dans le
secteur
gouvernement veut imposer ses lois comme
celle qui nous a interdit de travailler
dans les mines
mais on n'a pas vraiment le choix dans
ce pays si on ne bosse pas du on risque
de devenir un délinquant et de blé ou
tuer pour survivre
le gouvernement nous fait du tort avec
ses doigts car les jeunes risquent de
devenir des vagabonds et d'oublier ce
qu'est le travail honnête
alors moi je crois que là encore mais
puisaye la tâche mais au moins je ne
prends pas une mauvaise voie comme de
devenir guérilleros il ya tellement de
violence en colombie que vouloir
empêcher les enfants de travailler
honnêtement moi je dis c'est criminel et
en france est ce que les jeunes
travaillent aussi dans les mines
sinon parce que ici on est tous obligés
de le faire
on vit comme des taupes sous terre sans
jamais voir la lumière du jour
on voudrait bien faire autre chose mais
quoi ici il n'ya que le charbon comme
alternative on rentre à la maison vers
six heures du soir on est épuisé et dans
ces conditions on ne peut pas étudier
sérieusement
alors évidemment j'ai pris beaucoup de
retard dans mes études mais je ne perds
pas l'espoir de réussir un jour il faut
que l'an prochain je trouve un autre
boulot pour m'en sortir je n'ai pas
envie de croupir toute ma vie dans un
trou
[Musique]
lorsque je descends vie la socam au saut
je vois deux jolies filles j'aimerais
bien en avoir une pour moi mais ce n'est
pas possible parce que je suis qu'un
petit mineur et elle se moquerait moi
non je n'ai vraiment aucune chance avec
ses filles
alors quand je pioche au fond de la mine
je pense à elles et je rêve
[Musique]
pour une jeune fille de 7 ans comme moi
la municipalité est obligé de sacrifier
sa jeunesse pour survie mais c'est ainsi
j'aimerais tellement que les pères de
famille empêchent leurs enfants de
travailler décède à la rue parce que ce
n'est pas humain
ici il y a trop de jeunes familles qui
pleurent à cause de ça ici
le gouvernement lui s'en fout on ne se
rend pas compte qu'on souffre ici
j'aimerais tellement considérer occupe
un peu de nous l' acia sa radio
si on arrive à survivre c'est grâce à
dieu parce que chez moi tout le monde
travaille sans exception
mon mari m'a abandonné lorsque les
enfants était tout petit il ne m'a même
pas laissé une photo de lui ni le
moindre peu dos voilà pourquoi je suis
obligé de faire travailler mes propres
enfants
les pauvres ils ne connaissent même pas
l'école primaire leur école à m c'est la
mine
c'est un péché de laisser descendre
ainsi des mômes dans ce 3 rhin on vit
comme des bêtes on ne peut même pas se
tenir debout toute la journée on reste
les anglais et c'est encore plus
éprouvant de travailler ainsi
on souffre de crampes aux jambes et en
plus ce filon de charbon est dure à
casser la mine
ce n'est pas un endroit pour une femme
comme moi c'est trop difficile
regardez mes mains comme elles sont
sales et fatigué de piocher sans arrêt
elles sont pleines de corps
moi je gagne moins qu'un homme
parce que je produis peut évidemment
j'arrive à peine à 15 francs par jour
oui ce qu'on vit ici si de l'esclave
osita tu as sorti combien aujourd'hui un
quart de tonne à la galerie était en bon
état plus ou moins bien et toi petit
combien pas grand chose que toi combien
un quart de tonne aussi et le plafond où
il tient toujours
bof mais ça ira quand même dur à casser
sa wii très dur même que face aux
phobies en venir à bout pour gagner sa
croûte
oui patron on espère que dieu la vierge
nous garde en vie pour qu'on puisse
revenir demain exactement et à la
première heure fait le signe de croix
descendu au fond bien par vous
il est galerie de ma mine sont basses
c'est parce que le filon de charbon et
t3 ici alors évidemment il faut creuser
acheter oui c'est dur pour ces frappes
mais que voulez vous elles n'ont pas de
ressources et dans les autres mines
personnes land allemand du travail pour
nourrir leurs enfants je les ai donc
embauché faut être sympa avec ces gens
parce qu'ils ne mangent pas à leur faim
et moi je me sens un peu leur
bienfaiteur travailler dans la nuit ça
déforme mon corps regardez mes jambes
les bras
ce sont ceux d'un homme et pas d'une
jeune fille je n'aime pas voir merci
l'ouest et transformer ainsi mais je
n'ai pas vraiment le choix
j'ai les poumons encrassés de houille
lorsque je n'en peux plus lorsque
j'étouffe je sors respirer un peu
[Applaudissements]
lorsqu'on tombe malade
on n'a ni sécurité sociale ni l'aide
d'un syndicat on n'a rien et le patron
lui s'en fout toujours ces gens là
lorsqu on les embauche on les prévient
on leur dit on au fil du goulot d'accord
mais on n'est pas responsable si vous
arrivez le moindre pépin
alors moi j'ai bonne conscience au moins
ils bossent des protos ne revient pas
mon style a annoncé pour le 3ème tour
des moutons pour le coup pas l'ami
pourquoi
[Musique]
j'ai tout mis dans le temps triste et
bienvenue c'est ce qui s'appelle y voit
le dernier
[Musique]
et ça va pas
il y avait 800 mhz et pèse entre nous
féminin belle manière ce nombre par les
fruits
[Musique]
on a créé cette coopérative en mai 92
pour offrir une alternative aux enfants
mineurs de la région
ici nous avons deux activités la
sculpture sur charbon et la confection
de vêtements de travail
les enfants font surtout des figurines
précolombienne des cendriers des
presse-papier autres gadgets
ses sculptures sont ensuite vendus aux
touristes
[Musique]
la coopérative récupère 20% du prix de
l'objet pour ses frais de fonctionnement
et les 80% restants sont pour les gosses
par exemple avec cette figurine à
l'enfant gagne 10 francs pour une
demi-journée de travail soit
l'équivalent de la moitié du salaire
minimum du pays
[Musique]
seule une minorité des enfants de la
région travaillent ici on voudrait
qu'ils soient tous là mais on ne peut
pas les obliger à venir
beaucoup ont fait un passage éclair à
l'atelier parce qu'il ne gagnait rien
durant leur apprentissage
alors qu'à la mine on les paye le jour
même
moi même j'ai dû pousser la brouette
quand j'avais 11 ans et parfois je
pleurais d'épuisement ou d'avoir trop
soit on travaillait tous les jours de 6
heures du matin à 5 heures du soir
vraiment ce ne sont pas des conditions
humaines ni acceptables pour des enfants
c'est pour cela que je lutte pour la
survie de notre coopérative
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en un instant
donc ils m'attaquent de la main rouge à
quimper
leur maman et rosanne chapeauroux l'aï
leur histoire ça me rend très triste je
les suppliais plusieurs fois d'arrêter
de piocher dans la mine mais cette
pauvre femme n'a pas de quoi nourrir
correctement ses propres enfants
alors elle s'échine à la tâche comme un
miséreux et demain qu'est ce qu'ils vont
devenir
le manana
qui est maintenant temps de marche mais
là les quatre moi aussi je travaillais
la mine mais j'ai la chance de pouvoir
aller à l'école le matin pour avoir plus
tard un bon métier j'essaye sincèrement
disais ma meilleure amie milena en lui
donnant des leçons particulières pour
qu'elle rattrape son hôte un signe un
peu que j'apprends avec martha ne sera
toujours utile car dans cette région on
est condamné à travailler comme des
bêtes dans la même si on n'étudie pas
grâce à mon ami j'espère pouvoir m'en
sortir un jour ce que j'en serai
vraiment capable la meilleure
possibilité d'éditer
parce que c'est le week-end de paye
alors je rentre au village
dans ma famille voir si tout va bien ma
mère mes petits frères et soeurs c'est
important de se préoccuper de ses
proches
je travaille loin d'eux et il me manque
la dernière fois que j'ai joué j'ai fait
un match de foot
c'était sympa cette ville lorsque
j'étais enfant mais aujourd'hui je me
sens plutôt adulte je peux me prendre en
charge tout seul
et j'aurais honte de redevenir un gosse
moi ça fait cinq ans que je crie alors
vouloir vivre comme un enfant mon âge
c'est trop tard j'ai trop pris
l'habitude de travailler et rester
inactif à la maison sans gagner ma vie
c'est pas mon truc
non ce n'est pas pour moi alors il vaut
mieux je continue à la mine
là au moins je me sens bien avant de
descendre je fais toujours mon signe de
croix et en bas sous terre je me sens
protégée par le bon dieu et la sainte
vierge
[Musique]